northern nevada congressman mark amade  recently spoke on the health of the  economy across our state as it relates  to kovid  and the recent shutdowns he says the  challenge for state leaders is to find  the right balance between minimizing  fiscal destruction  and keep keeping people safe that is he  says the first step  is working with those impacted i'll tell  you the first way you start is you have  to talk to the people  on whom you're imposing those  restrictions  and so when you talk about what you do  with restaurants who's a who's a uh  who is who is a critical industry who  should be open who shouldn't be open  how all that is handled quite frankly  needs to be the subject of some  collaboration